mesdames messieurs monsieur monsieur le
président du sénat madame la présidente
de région
monsieur le président du conseil
départemental surtout mesdames et
messieurs les maires mes chers amis
mesdames messieurs nous inaugurons en
présence des personnalités j'allais dire
des poids lourds qui aurait été dans les
yvelines nous avons la chance d'avoir
valérie pécresse bien bédié et gérard
larcher qui actuellement est tout à fait
inoccupés et je le remercie
effectivement d'abord accepté de venir
célébrer ses 11e université auquel nous
sommes tous attachés et en particulier
j'ai un larcher
je crois que jamais jusqu'à ce jour nous
avons été aussi interrogatif sur le sort
des mères nous avons été malmenés et
trier mais toujours vaillant et je dois
dire que c'est dans la capacité de nos
institutions et de la bonne volonté des
maires femmes et hommes qui sont
toujours près du citoyen que nous sommes
et nous restons et nous resterons j'en
suis intimement convaincu le premier et
le dernier recours si nos reste qu'un ce
sera celui là ce sera celui du maire
avec peut-être des attributions
différentes
un exercice du pouvoir ou ce qu'il en
reste édulcoré puisque effectivement
j'ai l'impression et ça n'est pas qu'une
impression pour moi c'est une certitude
il ne faut pas tout attribuer au pouvoir
actuel les méfaits que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
à l'évidence nous avons subi un petit
strip tease désolé mesdames un strip
tease un effeuillage au fil des ans on
nous a retiré nos compétences les jeunes
après les autres et on nous demande
toujours effectivement encore plus
d'efforts avec moins de moyens
alors je rappelle simplement qu'en ce
qui concerne les collectivités locales
et vous pouvez en être fier sur les 2000
milliards de dettes un petit peu plus
maintenant
sur les 2000 milliards de dette de la
france vous ne représentez
nous ne représentons que 10% de cet
endettement tout le reste c'est l'état
mais l'état s'arroge des pouvoirs et des
libertés qu'ils nous refuse à nommer
fort heureusement d'ailleurs car
imaginez un peu si nous avions la
possibilité d'emprunter pour des frais
de fonctionnement
nous sommes l'investissement et rien
d'autre alors je crois sincèrement au
maire je crois alors aux communautés de
communes qui nous ont avalé plus ou
moins les communautés d'agglo les
communautés urbaines le département la
région et puis maintenant vous avez
quand même la chance d'avoir un petit
dessert supplémentaires les fameuses
comme une nouvelle qui ne sont ni plus
ni moins que les fusions avec le succès
que nous connaissons et j'attire
l'attention du président du sénat pour
lui dire que sur les 36 1683 commune
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec les fusions
de communes devenu comme une nouvelle
environ 35 1535 1506 demain n'ya plus
les communes nous serons à peu près de
1500 collectivités territoriales c'est à
dire moins de 10% alors arrondissant à
10%
imaginez 36000 nous reste plus que 2500
imaginer le sénat à 348 sénateurs 10 %
35 sénateurs l'assemblée de députés 577
députés 58 députés
voilà finalement une réforme
constitutionnelle que nous appelons
peut-être tous de notre voeu mais qui
frappent certainement pas l'unanimité
voilà mais c'est simplement pour donner
cet ordre de grandeur
alors je crois vraiment à votre capacité
de résilience j'en suis sûr nous ne
lâcherons pas nous sommes toujours très
proches de nos concitoyens ce sont des
gens de notre famille et ils se sont
toujours ceux là qui peuvent se diriger
vers nous ils seront toujours les biens
d'accueillir alors merci monsieur le
président du sénat car je sais que vous
avez un emploi du temps chargé d'avoir
accepté de venir valérie pécresse la
même chose pierre bédier aussi ce sont
nos trois poids lourds
ils s'adorent sous des formes diverses
et je vais leur cd successivement la
parole monsieur pierre bédier
faire tant d'efforts pour maigrir à se
faire traiter de poids lourds monsieur
le président à bord on entend peu et
monsieur le président de l'umih merci
merci d'avoir organisé cette belle
université avant que saluer le président
du sénat qui est le premier de tous les
élus locaux de france je voudrais saluer
la mère de marc demain de port marly
j'avais dire de marly alors là elle
allait définitivement mes tripes et elle
est là et elle m'a dit que si elle
n'était pas saluées par les quatre
orateurs il était possible que la
commission de sécurité ferme
enfin pas la commission vous l'avez
compris le lieu mes chers amis le
président pellicier a parlé des
feuillages mais c'est c'est son côté
coquin qui lui fait parler des
feuillages moi qui ait un côté comment
dit-on plus brutale je veux aussi parler
de braquage
parce que ça commençait à un effeuillage
mais ça a fini en braquage
je ne sais pas vous dans vos dgf mais
nous le braquage a été sur 85% de notre
dgf je le rappelle créant des conditions
financières extrêmement périlleuse
heureusement mes chers amis que d'une
part nous avons la chance dans les
yvelines d'avoir effectivement un
président du sénat qui sait mieux que
personne ce que la république doit aux
communes les communes en sont la base je
le dis d'autant plus que mr moi même il
y à quelques temps j'avais bien
conscience d'être le premier de cordée
puisqu'il paraît monsieur le sénateur
que où est ce qu'ils les sénateurs j'ai
aperçu pardon je me trompais de
moustachus
il paraît que les cordes et sont à la
mode et ben quand on est premier de
cordée dans une ville on se rend compte
que nos concitoyens ont besoin de ce
contact avec le maire mais le maire lui
il a besoin
un type comme dans un sport qui m'est
cher le rugby quand il a le ballon
d'avoir les groupes devant qui viennent
l'aider parce qu'autrement il se fait
caramélisées pour reprendre une
expression de rugby et donc sachez mes
chers amis mais cher ex collègues que la
volonté féroce farouche totale du
département des yvelines comme le
président du sénat nous défend et défend
de collectivités ou plus haut niveau de
l'état
comme valérie pécresse présidente de
région dans la politique régionale qui
est la sienne en direction des communes
nous sommes-nous département déterminer
quoi qu'on veuille faire à rester le
partenaire indispensable de vos communes
et d'être toujours là pour tous vos
besoins
c'est pourquoi nous multiplions les
politiques contractuelles
vous avez bien vu depuis trois ans que
tous les secteurs toutes les tailles de
communes sont concernées qu'il s'agisse
du secteur rural
qu'il s'agisse des secteurs de politique
de la ville qu'il s'agisse des aides
financières mais aussi des aides
opérationnelles comme la création
d'activité qu'il s'agisse des aides sur
le quart en semant monsieur le maire de
versailles
c'est un sujet qui vous est cher et qui
m'est cher aussi même si nous ne
partageons pas toujours les voies pour y
parvenir mais en tous les cas l'objectif
est bien le même
il est impératif il est impératif que le
couple commune département choix encore
et toujours au service de nos
concitoyens alors je sais que dans un
nouveau monde
il faut faire table rase de l'ancien
mais réfléchissons à deux fois avant
d'oublier cet ancien monde qui depuis
deux siècles depuis deux siècles
structure la france structure la france
institutionnellement c'est la république
mais structure la france aussi dans son
aménagement du territoire qui d'entre
nous
voyageant dans notre beau pays allant
dans les départements les moins peuplés
les plus éloignés ne constate pas
combien ce pays est bien aménagé
combien se payer différents de ce point
de vue de ses voisins européens
et cela on le doit au couple commune
département qui aujourd'hui bien entendu
sont appuyés par la région en
particulier à l'île de france
voilà pourquoi mes chers amis je vous le
redis aujourd'hui avec force et
détermination
le département des yvelines sera plus
que jamais aux côtés des maires des
yvelines
[Applaudissements]
madame la maire cher marcel
qui nous accueille je voudrais saluer le
président du sénat le président du
département le président de
l'association des maires dire que je
souscris complètement est absolument à
tout ce qui a été dit par dix pélissier
et pierre bédier
mais moi je voudrais qu'on soit très
très concrets comme celle elle semblait
des mers et que j'ai pas souvent
l'occasion de vous avoir tout sous la
main
je voudrais juste vous parlez très
concrètement on a compris que l'état se
désengage est et qui vous laisser avec
pas grand chose on a compris aussi avec
pierre bédier qu'il fallait qu'on soit
puissamment en soutien de nos mères qui
sont finalement les instruments d'un
orchestre départemental et plus
largement régionales donc on veut que
vous jouiez pleinement de votre bel
instrument municipal et pour ça on est à
on est à un an et on ne rit pas parce
que la paillardise de cette association
de mer commence à devenir un petit peu
préoccupants voilà non je plaisante mais
tout ça pour dire que vous êtes un an de
vaud municipal un peu plus allant des
municipales vous avez tous encore
certainement des projets et vous ne
savez pas forcément comment les financer
comment les réaliser et vous ne savez
pas forcément tout ce que la région peut
faire pour vous donc vous allez me
pardonner de faire une petite une petite
liste exhaustive de ce qu'on peu de
partout on peut vous aider mais je pense
que ce sera pas inutile pour certains
d'entre vous et que certains d'entre
vous ne se diront peut-être mais tilt je
n'avais pas pensé que la région pouvait
aider ce type de projet je vous dis ça
parce que j'arrive de
saint-germain-en-laye où nous avons avec
arnaud péricard et les maires de
l'intercommunalité de la forêt de saint
germain
nous avons lancé l'idée d'un faux de de
pouvoir aider au nettoyage de tous les
dépôts sauvages dans le cadre du fonds
propres étaient de la région dans la
forêt de saint germain en laye et nous
lançons à titre expérimental toujours
dans la forêt de saint-germain-en-laye
mais je disais au maire de rambouillet
mai et à tous les maires qui sont ici
qu'on pourrait le faire dans d'autres
territoires des yvelines une application
à ces déchets
à ces déchets que tous les promeneurs
des yvelines pourront avoir sur leur
smartphone tige avec laquelle ils
pourront photographier les dépôts
sauvages et la photo joël géolocaliser
arrivera directement dons aux services
techniques de la ville qui sera
partenaire de à ces déchets pour aider à
ce que dans le cadre d'une politique de
de tolérance zéro pour les déchets
sauvages qu'on puisse immédiatement
nettoyé soit les espaces publics soit la
forêt qui auraient été impactés
donc on vient de lancer à ses déchets en
expérimentation dans la forêt de saint
germain mais ça peut tout à fait venir
chez vous la propreté étant la première
des choses que vos concitoyens vous
demande en tant que maire la deuxième
chose et ça ne va pas vous surprendre
c'est les transports les transports
c'est la région vous l'avez tous bien
compris
alors il ya des projets de très grande
envergure qu'on finance évidemment à
plus long terme
eole un plan anti bouchons avec avec un
certain nombre de nouvelles liaisons
routières le tram 13 saint cyr saint
germain puis hr poissy qu'on a lancé
mais c'est pas de ça que je vous parle
je vous parlais de vos projets très
concrets
nous avons encore 7000 places de parking
sécurisé velits go pour les vélos que
nous allons nous allons construire d'ici
2020 donc demandé nous des places de
parking vélio pour vos citoyens
demandez-nous des places de parkings
relais
nous construisons aussi des milliers de
places de parking relais je sais que le
département finance aussi mais nous
sommes là à vos côtés pour financer ces
parkings relais
nous finançons dans les gares des
espaces de coworking hangar
alors il ya les gros espace de coworking
concots finances dans les villes il ya
un certain nombre d' espaces de
coworking qui sont déjà lancés comme à
jouars pontchartrain
mais il des micros ou working hangar
avec la sncf c'est aussi possible
et qu'est ce que ça fait bien ça permet
à tous vos habitants ne pas prendre le
train le train bondé de 8 heures mais de
télétravail est une heure une heure et
demie et de prendre le train vide de
9h30 c'est la politique de lissage des
heures de pointe qui est tellement
importante pour améliorer la qualité de
vie dans les yvelines
nous lancerons aussi cet été je le dis
pour les mères qui sont intéressés une
offre de vélos de location de vélos
électriques longue durée parce que les
yvelines ça n'est pas plat et donc une
offre de location de vélos électriques
longue durée ça peut être chez vous ça
peut être dans votre gare ça peut être
dans votre vie voilà donc je tiens à
vous dire pareil le plan vélo régional
se déploie on n'a pas attendu l'état
pour nous expliquer qu'il fallait faire
un plan qui aide à l'est à franchir les
frontières des communes c'est le plan
vélo régional n'hésitez pas on finance
gambe et versailles mantes la jolie mais
il ya plein d'autres villes qui
pourraient être financés
alors au delà
des de la propreté et des transports le
logement le logement et l'anru puisque
il ya j'ai vu la maire de chanteloup
nous sommes là pour vous aider la région
a décidé que dans le cadre de l'anru
pour les quartiers populaires elle
s'occuperait particulièrement de tout ce
qui est commerce sécurité équipements
publics espaces verts donc vraiment
n'hésitez pas à candidater de même pour
vos projets de logement vous êtes tous
soumis à la loi sru
tous ou presque et vous il vous faut
construire nous avons une aide au
financement des quartiers écologiques et
innovant et donc vous pouvez là encore
candidate et aux finances déjà 56
quartier il faut vous contredit dattiers
l'outil principal que nous avons de
coopération avec les maires c'est le
contrat d'aménagement régional pour les
villes de plus de 2000 habitants et le
contrat rural pour les villages dans ces
deux cas nous avons augmenté puissamment
nos crédits pour 2019
nous l'avons augmenté plus amont au
crédit parce que nous savons que c'est
la dernière année utile pour vous donc
n'hésitez pas infrastructures sportives
infrastructures médicales
infrastructures équipements scolaires
n'hésitez pas candidaté la région a
adapté ses budgets d'investissement on
va augmenter de 25 % le montant pour que
vos projet puisse se réaliser et on a
complètement assoupli les choses puisque
vous pouvez avoir qu'un seul projet
désormais à faire et pas deux ou trois
pour aller plus vite
voilà donc vraiment on est là n'hésitez
pas à faire appel à nous de même si vous
avez des friches urbanisme transitoire
nous avons un projet pour aider à
utiliser ces friches et construire soit
du social soit du commerce du culturel
n'hésitez pas c'est le plan urbanisme
transitoire dernier sujet d'enjôler vous
parlez
la sécurité toutes les demandes de ces
curés d'équipements de sécurité seront
honorés voilà tout nous avons déjà
financé trois mille caméras dans toute
l'île de france depuis que nous sommes
arrivés et nous allons continuer donc
n'hésitez pas l'équipement des polices
municipales la sécurisation des espaces
publics la vidéoprotection tout ça c'est
le bouclier de sécurité nous sommes
derrière vous et nous allons le financer
dernière chose les lycées les lycées
nous étions très très très très très en
retard et les yvelines était
particulièrement mal servi par la
précédente mandature donc on a livré 10
opérations depuis 2016 mon en train de
mettre les bouchées doubles on a dix
opérations de rénovation en cours
32 inscrits au pays et là aussi on va
accélérer
si votre lycée a été oubliée venaient
vers nous n'hésitez pas j'ajoute que je
remercie le département parce qu'avec
que son aide
nous avons mis tous les lycées au très
haut débit dès cette année enfin un mot
sur la culture et ce sera le dernier
cette fois ci le vraiment dernier nous
avons doublé notre plan rénovation du
patrimoine qui est passé de 5 à 10
millions d'euros
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
vous aide on a déjà rénové ces églises
participé à la rénovation de ces églises
mais on peut aussi faire du patrimoine
rural on peut faire du patrimoine
industriel et rénove on vous aide
on aide les musées et la fondation du
patrimoine alain schmitz et peut-être
par là un partenariat avec nous c'est à
dire qu'on peut faire un euro de la
fondation du patrimoine en crowdfunding
auprès des habitants égal 1 euros de la
région
voilà sur le sport sport oxygène j'en ai
parlé vos infrastructures sportives
notre plan c'est au moins une
infrastructure sportive par commune et
encore 10 % des communes qui n'ont pas
d'infrastructures sportives
donc nous serons là et tout cela pour
vous dire quoi que nous sommes
solidaires de la grande couronne que les
grands banlieusards ne sont pas des
citoyens de seconde zone et que là où la
région donnée 2 milliards à paris et 800
millions d'euros aux yvelines
eh bien nous nous rééquilibrer nos
crédits en fonction pas en fonction du
nombre d'habitants et non plus j'allais
dire tout pour paris et rien pour la
petite et la grande couronne
voilà donc au pensio vous ayez des
projets on vous êtes merci madame la
présidente de région comme vous voyez
quand une femme prend la parole et qu'on
lui accorde cinq minutes ce sont cinq
minutes de coiffeur mais extrêmement
résumé je pourrais vous dire que
finalement si vous n'avez plus rien dans
les poches avec elle c'est noël vous
pouvez y aller
vous avez pouvez demander de l'argent
monsieur le préfet
mais pas n'importe quoi des choses bien
ciblés monsieur le préfet book est
responsable de tous nos maux je serais
ravi que vous puissiez effectivement
venir ici
je sais qu'il a des lunettes
merveilleuse derrière lesquels il tente
à se cacher mais c'est toujours
sympathique de recevoir le préfet que
vous puissiez l'identifier il vous
connaît déjà vous inquiétez pas il a
toutes vos fiches donc ce sera parfait
je vais maintenant céder la parole
effectivement monsieur le président du
sénat qui lui a effectivement un temps
légèrement plus important mais qui nous
apporte des bonnes nouvelles mais je
vous rassure c'est pas levé le ministre
l'intérieur bien madame le maire leur
port marly
monsieur le préfet de notre département
monsieur le président de l'association
des maires des yvelines
madame la présidente du conseil régional
monsieur le président du conseil
départemental devrait saluer mes
collègues députés et sénateurs vous
saluer mes chers collègues maires maires
adjoints conseillers municipaux faire un
clin d'oeil au président de
l'association des maires des
hauts-de-seine jacques gauthier et faire
un clin d'oeil à un président deux
grandes communautés d'une vie aquatique
et thermales dominique dord qui nous
vient de sa voix que j'aperçois ici avec
et j'ai beaucoup partagé et vous tous
plaisir
monsieur le président de me retrouver
dans cette assemblée d'une association
que dans une vie antérieure
monsieur le préfet j'ai présidé de se
lever aussi des sous préfets que je vois
ici présents et qui sur le terrain sont
le relais et la présence de l'êta si
importante à nos yeux
l'an dernier je vous avais promis
quelque jours après le choix des
délégués sénatoriaux des yvelines qu'on
reviendrait vers vous avec un certain
nombre de sujets et le dossier et si
vous le voulez bien je commencerai par
vous parler du projet de loi est lent
sur le logement parce que je vais vous
parler concret de problèmes auxquels
vous êtes confrontés et jeudi devant
monsieur le préfet et sous préfet qui a
été gérée dans notre département souvent
dans un rapport compréhensif avec l'état
mais en même temps et nous fallait faire
évoluer la loi
les lois
et d'ailleurs j'avais proposé au
président de la république vous en
souvenez peut-être que nous changions de
méthode sur ce sujet et que nous
commencions par une conférence de
consensus et je dois dire que le
résultat sous réserve du vote final qui
vous est proposé c'est sans doute pas
monsieur le président pellicier le
nirvana mais c'est le retour sur un
chemin raisonnée raisonnable et qui peut
être un point de départ d'un certain
nombre d'évolutions et je voudrais le
dire parce que nous le devons notamment
à celle qui a présidé la conférence de
consensus qui est sénatrice de ce
département
c'est sophie primas qui a porté cette
évolution
quelles sont les avancées obtenues dans
un dialogue avec nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale et dans l'ain
dialogue
avec jacques mézard qui me donne
l'occasion de rendre hommage à ce
ministre de la cohésion les territoires
pour dire que des avancées notables ont
pu être obtenues tout particulièrement
dans les grandes opérations d'urbanisme
monsieur le maire de versailles
le maire a été réintroduit au coeur des
politiques de l'habitat
le second des poids nous avons simplifié
sécuriser un certain nombre de normes
d'urbanisme il en reste beaucoup il en
reste beaucoup trop mais pour la
première fois on va vers la diminution
de ce nombre de normes
troisièmement nous avons obtenu un
certain nombre d'avancées pour les
territoires en matière de logement
social de revitalisation des
centres-villes et des centres bourgs
d'ailleurs à partir d'une proposition de
loi issue du sénat dans la diversité
comme souvent sénat majorité sénatoriale
et opposition d'un socialiste
aida républicains notamment sur les
centres bourgs et les centres villes
nous avons obtenu des avancées en
matière de lutte contre l'habitat
indigne de lutte monsieur le préfet
contre les squats
[Musique]
et concernant les locataires condamné
pour trafic de stupéfiants il se voyait
protégé comme tous les citoyens de la
même manière
je voudrais vous parler d'eux et chez
rue de manière très concrète
les communes entrant dans le dispositif
et 6 rue pour la première fois
disposeront désormais de cinq périodes
triennales pour atteindre leurs
objectifs
ça change la donne c'est pas l'idéal
mais comme on se reverra d'ici 15 ans je
pense que nous pourrons faire évoluer
les choses avec mon sens nous aurons une
expérimentation je pense pour les maires
notamment du grand paris seine et oise
mais pas uniquement eux permettant aux
communes ayant 20 % de logements sociaux
de mutualiser la construction de ces
logements tous un certain nombre de
conditions c'est à dire de dépasser les
limites communales
troisième des choses
les logements occupés par un titulaire
d'un prêt social location-accession le
ps est là et les logements faisant
l'objet d'un bail réel solidaires seront
décomptés dans la liste des logements
sociaux
enfin point important en ile de france
madame la présidente
le seuil des communes éligibles loi sru
sont rapportés à 3500 habitants pour les
communes d'île de france située en
dehors de l'unité urbaine de paris
ça concerne de ta mort parce qu'il faut
parler concret chez nous aux farges is
gone l oif bullion cerner la ville
guerville mort à villiers ou son champ
voilà des choses concrètes et réelles
dans lesquelles nous étions dans une
prise de tête global
voilà quelques-uns des apports ils sont
concrets je dois vous le dire
au delà des discours c'est je l'espère
ce qui sera votée dans les jours qui
viennent conjointement par l'assemblée
nationale et par le sénat dans un
dialogue qui est un dialogue nécessaire
où chacun a pu faire valoir ses
positions
autre thème d'actualité monsieur le
préfet et je voudrais le tournant vers
vous et les sous-préfets évoquer un
sujet pour lequel je le sais le maire de
rambouillet et le président de cette
communauté à une écoute attentif c'est
la question notamment des gens du voyage
le sénat a adopté en première lecture
une proposition de loi visant retrouver
un équilibre entre droits et devoirs les
gens du voyage et des collectivités
chargées de l'accueil fin juin
l'assemblée nationale a repris la
proposition de loi qui était notamment
porté par des élus de haute savoie et de
savoie chez nous oui
l'assemblée nationale la reprise fin
juin en acceptant les mesures proposées
est attendue notamment la menthe
forfaitaire délictuelle en quarts
de campements illicites ou la prise en
compte des efforts réalisés par une
commune ayant respecté ses engagements
au sein d'un opci qui n'auraient pas
encore rempli toutes les conditions en
matière d'accueil des gens du voyage
nous souhaitons et ça a été un débat
hier dans les groupes politiques
confirmé ces avancées mais retravailler
sur d'autres points qui n'avait pas été
retenu par l'assemblée nationale et qui
au sénat avait fait un large consensus
ce sont notamment les procédures
d'évacuation des campements illicites et
je vous le dis au sénat au delà
d'ailleurs des clivages politiques
nous ne céderons pas concrètement sur ce
point
revenir et le sujet a été évoqué par le
président pellicier par le président du
conseil départemental
bien sûr la question de
l'intercommunalité
la question de la relation entre
l'exécutif et les territoires et cette
question ne l'enjeu de subsidiarité et
de la participation des mères aux
instances de décision des
intercommunalités
nous avons une mission qui rendra ses
propositions le 24 octobre prochain
c'est une mission à l'intérieur de la
commission des lois et je dois le dire
qu'on ne peut pas je les dis au
président de la république je le redirai
au ministre en charge
on ne peut pas rester dans cette
situation de blocage des relations entre
l'exécutif et les collectivités
territoriales de la république
c'est sans doute moins sensible en
yvelines mais quand vous êtes en
haute-garonne et que vous constatez que
depuis fin juin
trente sept mers en démissionner
que depuis le début de l'année ce sont
des milliers et des milliers de
conseillers municipaux qui ont
démissionné pourquoi parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment de ne plus servir à rien de ne
plus être consultées de ne plus partager
et il faut qu'on trouve et ce sera
l'objet d'ailleurs d'un élément du
rapport n'ont pas des lois
supplémentaires mais sans doute des
pratiques
différentes car on ne peut pas se
séparer de cette trame des cinq cent
mille élus locaux comment associer les
maires et les élus locaux à la
gouvernance nous le voyons bien les
grandes intercommunalités qui ont la
taille de mes chemises xxl recompte dans
le pays
un certain nombre de difficultés et pas
simplement en yvelines passablement dans
la vallée de la seine et il va falloir
que nous réfléchissions notamment à des
territorialisation de la gouvernance
mais aussi à des assouplissements jeudi
devant monsieur le préfet suis pas
certain que la voirie et les espaces
verts gérer au théâtre saint denis comme
aux mureaux de la même manière
centralisée ça soit la réponse adaptée
et nous allons faire des propositions
dans ce sens
alors mes chers amis vous le sentez bien
il ya eu un appel à marseille
je me suis associé je me suis associé
tout comme le sénat et moi même nous
continuer à participer aux conférences
nationales des territoires parce que je
pense que notre rôle dans la diversité
de nos sensibilités
ici les sénateurs c'est d'être ceux qui
permettent que des mains tendues les
unes vers les autres se croisent enfin
dans l'intérêt du pays
je le redis on heureux ne sera pas notre
pays et nous avons tous quel que soit
notre sensibilité la volonté de
redresser notre pays
moi je me satisfais pas d'un premier
semestre à 0 4% de croissance corps
recevant la présidente de la première
chambre donc senna néerlandais lors
d'hésitations sur leurs premiers mois c
est ce qu'ils ont fait 1 4 ou 1 6 et
donc
nous avons tous ensemble besoin de
redresser notre pays mais je les dis au
président je le redis publiquement on
euro ne restera pas notre pays qu'en
contres ou sans les territoires sans ou
contre les élus c'est vraiment un sujet
et le dernier les sujets pardonnez moi
d'être un peu long ça va être le sujet
de la réforme
de la réforme des ressources fiscales
notamment des collectivités que le
gouvernement a annoncé pour le premier
semestre et je souhaite que cette
réforme soit l'occasion d'une reprise de
dialogue tout simplement reprenant le
discours du président de la république
devant l'assemblée des maires de france
à l'automne dernier
on se met autour d'une table bien sûr
les commissions parlementaires
on se met autour d'une table bien sûr le
gouvernement mais au sommet aussi autour
d'une table avec les associations d'élus
on ne pourra pas tenir de nouvelles
conférences nationales des territoires
sans les représentants des maires de
france des départements de france et des
régions de france et pour fâcher
dominique bussereau cher président bédié
faut quand même le faire et donc si je
vous dis ça c'est que je pense qu'il ya
une question de méthode
je l' ai proposé publiquement premier
ministre a marseille je les reprends
posait devant les ministres la semaine
dernière à deauville
parce qu'on est fait on ne pourra pas
jouer qu'au bonneteau je te redonne le
foncier bâti les départements
tu seras content et je donne une
fraction de la peau nationale j'aurais
simplement vous lire
deux lignes d'un rapport d'une agence de
notation standard & poor publié le 3
octobre dernier
si nous appliquions la cinquième
proposition c'est à dire le cinquième
scénario et je pense qu'il y en aura un
sixième je le souhaite
du transfert du foncier bâti au
département
la part de leurs recettes fiscales
modifiable mais si vous savez ce que ça
veut dire les passerait de 23 % des
recettes de fonctionnement à 2%
nous avons un problème constitutionnel
d'autonomie des collectivités
territoriales nous ne sommes pas un pays
fédéral
donc on ne fonctionnera pas la manière
allemande et donc nous sommes là sur un
vrai sujet voilà les sujets pardonnez
moi sans grandes envolées dont je
voulais vous parler c'est la vie
concrète des collectivités car faire le
métier de maire tout le monde connaît ma
formule c est rapportée d'engueulades
mais en plus des engueulades
ils ont pu d'argent ils ont des normes
et des contraintes
il faut qu'on les libère de tout ça un
peu je le dis sans populisme aucun c'est
ce à quoi nous essayons de travailler
l'exemple du logement a montré qu'il
n'était pas impossible que le dialogue
nous permettent d'avancer les uns vers
les autres
merci très bonnes universités bien
mesdames messieurs les maires simplement
le temps passe comme vous savez on a
pratiquement 1000 inscrits ce qui est un
record mais pratiquement neuf cents
personnes également à des jeunes et dont
je vous invite cordialement à vous
rendre à la salle pour celles et ceux
qui connaissent directement c'est la
salle opposés et je profite également de
cette occasion pour vous dire que le
président pierre bédier
lorsque vous allez vous diriger vers la
salle de restaurant et il y as et le
stand effectivement du département et il
vous offre sauf erreur de ma part du
champagne mais il est parti donc je
pense que c'est bon quand même ce sera
de champagne et merci madame le maire de
port marly nous avoir accueillis si
gentiment je vous avais oublié mais vous
savez que je vous ai dans mon coeur